when we talk to people we sit there with
their resume and we ask them questions
about their resume you know and that has
a role but who are they as a person and
when I'm getting to know somebody as a
candidate for a job I want to talk to
them socially I want to go out for
coffee with them I want to take them for
lunch I want to talk to them about their
family I want to find out who they are
because at the end of the day what makes
somebody a great contributor to our
culture is their value set if they're
missing a skill set we can teach that
it's really the values that make
somebody a great contributor to culture
in the Marine Corps for example they
take their best and brightest off the
front lines and they do a tour in
recruiting and that's because they want
their best and brightest the people who
best embody the culture the people who
best embody the values to go out and
find people who they believe would
continue to protect the values of the
organization and so I I think that's
what we should do as well I think
recruiting should be done by the best
and brightest and smartest and the
people who love the company and love the
team and they're super protective of the
team they should determine who gets in
they should be a part of it